let's consider a one-dimensional motion
that has a non uniform acceleration what
we'd like to do is explore how do you
differentiate position functions to get
philosophy functions to get acceleration
function so what we're going to consider
is a rocket so I'm going to choose a
coordinate system Y and here's my rocket
and I have the function y of T and I'll
have a J hat direction but this will be
a one-dimensional motion now I want to
express while the rocket is thrusting
upwards and the engine is burning we can
describe a function y of T to be equal
to one-half a constant a naught minus
the gravitational acceleration times T
squared and we're going to have a
separate term here which is minus 1 over
30 and you'll see where this 30 comes in
as we start to differentiate same
constant a naught T to the sixth over T
naught to the fourth now in this
expression a naught is bigger than G and
also this is only true this holds for
the time interval 0 less than or equal
to t less than T naught and at time T
equals to T naught the engine shuts off
and at that moment our expectation will
be that the Y component of the
acceleration should just be minus G for
T greater than T naught so now let's
calculate the acceleration as the
velocity and the position as functions
of time so the velocity in each case
we're going to use the polynomial rule
so the Y component of the velocity is
just the different derivative of T
squared which is just 2t and so we get a
naught minus G times T and when we
differentiate T to the sixth the 6 over
30 gives us a factor 1 over 5 so we have
minus 1 over 5 times a naught T to the
fifth
over T not to the fourth and this is a
combination of a linear term and a term
that is decreasing by this T to the
fifth factor and finally we now take the
next derivative a Y of T which is d dy
DT I'll just keep functions of T but we
don't really need that and when we
differentiate here we get a naught minus
G now you see the 5s are cancelling and
we have minus a naught T to the fourth
over T naught to the fourth now at time
T equals T naught what do we have well a
Y at T equals T naught this is just a
factor minus a naught those cancel and
we get minus G which is what we expected